ari takes out of line of $360,000 policy
remember I encourage to you as you plan
interpret questioning to write down
whatever information is into it its
discretion is too long for us to trying
to get all the way through the end and
then write anything down so I'm just
gonna do this as we go okay so the first
thing that I see is $360,000 what is
this feeling
what does it mean it's the loan total
amount right so this is because that's
one of my ideas that's the first piece
of information you just stopped being
whenever you feel like there's another
piece eventually we should write down
the mother is to be repaid in people
monthly repayments and dollars okay so
we should stop you just there any goals
now here's the plus team that is more
challenging about this question than the
superannuation signature oh yeah you
don't know what this is
so immediately assumes you put
contrarian instead of actual numbers
things sort of branch it up a bit more
difficulty because they how do they just
be more complicated to do so M dollars
is the equal monthly repayments now just
before I go on and read more I'm gonna
say immediately this is another of the
reasons why this question is generally
viewed as hotter than superannuation
when you'll repaint something you start
with a figure and instead of adding on
you are subtracting right there -
silence I kind of you know this huge
area difficulty that we always have in
terms of factoring out dates forgetting
on my side etc so it's not like it's
immensely difficult subtraction versus
addition but it is kind of something
that you want to be careful for you see
go and Allah sees at the end of this
month
yeah when when is the payment this month
into the end of them do you think they
tell you that by accident
no it's so that you know when we fought
the equations later on when certain
things happen when you do this when to
do that that affects your order of
operations okay let's get going at the
end of each month
over 25 years which is pretty much ha
thank you okay there's something stop me
25 years so this is the oh this is the
line for the one okay
so 25 years 300 months is the line
so presumably I mean but at the end of
30 years we want to completely have
wiped away that death yeah make sense
reduce somewhat interest is charged at
six percent per annum thank you so say
it impacted really dense right they
don't give you too much blush so even
though it's a long question everything
is pretty much as brief as we could make
it so six percent that they say is per
annum but they then say it's calculated
monthly so because it's a monthly fee
which by the way is why they said 300
months this six percent friend is
actually not really the figure I want
what is this per month
see to serve how many months are there
there were twelve months in a year so I
divide that by 12 which gives me half a
percent per month does that make sense
so you can see how much I energy effort
leads to invested just to unpack the
question and then one of the young
selling details okay and then we
actually come to they ask us topic how
one actually started take that back
so let a n dollars be what is this every
this is the amount away at what point in
time this is almost to the end payment
after the
and you might feel like my goodness you
just rewrote the entire question we
always did as a few disappear connecting
words you didn't put there let me just
go right out there and say the 30
seconds it took you to write this it's
the most important phase you're spending
the entire question because if obviously
you get any of these parts of the setup
wrong
I don't care how also the next 10
minutes of your working arm if there's
just a basic premise is incorrect okay
so I feel like this is the equipment of
joining the diagram you know it's time
that the contagion they are ok let's
start to ask this question it says write
down an expression for the amount going
up two months which is a suit okay now
did you get what we did the
superannuation question we built it up
step by step and they say you know write
down an expression and there's just a
mark on it but I still want to see we're
capable so the first thing I'm going to
do before you get to a me-too
is I'm going to write down a 1 what
happens
well a 1 meaning that going after the
payment right so two things happening
before that actually takes place right
you start with your $360,000 and there
are gonna be two things that happen how
oh look we've written them down in the
question what are the two things that
happen to reduce thought maybe obvious
one the best any one is the amount only
off the independent so that means that
this this is going to happen the end all
isn't in your table right but if there's
something else it's implied in the
question usually area
the interest which is here gets applied
now you tell me which do you think
happens first there are two clues that
tell you that the interest happens first
okay firstly banks are never going to
give you the option of reducing the
interest principle first before applying
their interest because if you make it
slow up they don't get to charge as much
interest so they just going to want to
do that first okay but there's another
questions another point rather even more
explicit in the question what tells you
we wrote it down then the issues were
going to play first the repayment
happens at the end of the month yeah so
I've got enough reason therefore to
assume obviously you conclude that that
amount there was owing first interest
gets applied to it so I multiply that by
what one point now just be careful be
careful cuz decimal places that's a
percentage right so if I won't say one
point not that would write this if I say
one point five
yes what what interest would that be
that's being applied open plus that's a
50% right says wrong
so for what 1.05 what would that be
they'll be 5% well that's not right
either right it's not going one point
zero zero five does that make sense
super common error because one point
zero five looks pretty reasonable and
will give you somewhat reasonable
numbers it's just about this question
okay interest has been applied in their
weapon and then we do the repayment
survey yeah because they're trying to
reduce the BeagleBone we subtract and
there's to be Hannah which I don't know
what's value with how you do that that's
a 1 now I need to repeat to work at a 2
so this yeah
a 1 that's what you stopped me and then
what's the immediate first thing that
happens it just gets fired right
and then I'm going to wait to apply
interest be like straight ways and that
must be can agents get suppliant and
then we do repayment but of course I
know what they want is I just
established it the previous line so I
can actually work out one evening so
there's the three it's got two lots of
interests that you can apply to it
there's this guy the first repayment and
then there's this time we can just get
ideally this look okay yeah we made some
hot money
but before we leave off I just want to
interpret what was its name and firstly
see how this two M's are here why their
tombs because two repayments of is not
my definition that's what ancient means
right so if for instance I have a five I
guess I would expect a five-episode
along here okay how about this guy how
about in this row you've got the
principal amount that started the event
you start with right and it's had to
lots of interest applied to it remember
I talked to you before about the fact
that when you do a superannuation you
can consider it all as one big lump sum
we actually can see that each of the
investments each year as a separate
thing games own interests right
so in offices though in this this amount
just sits there forever anthem up
forever in thirty years and she's gains
interest those thirty years
but what's fighting with it what sort of
playing a tug-of-war is all of these
guys you see at some point after thirty
years we've notified it is we hope these
dollars will end up getting so big on
their own that as subtraction they all
counteract the principle which just
keeps on growing and growing and growing
does that make sense got a picture in
your head of how this is working